Transcriber: Burak Yildiz
Gözden geçirme: Ilayda Gokgoz
Bir başka doğum hikayesi,
benim hikayem ve kızlarımın hikayesi.
Karından değil kalpten doğuran bir anneyim
ben ve kan bağıyla değil,
can bağıyla aile olma öyküsü bizim öykümüz
Bilinenden çok farklı,
normal algılamanın dışında
ve bilinmediği için de aslında
korkulan bir hikaye benim hikayem.
6 Mart 2014 tarihinde bir Çarşamba günü,
saat tam 11′de, Ankara’da Keçiören’de
bulunan Atatürk Çocuk Yuvası’ndan
içeriye girdim ve bir daha hayatım
asla eskisi gibi olmadı .
Bir gün önce, telefonlar almıştık ve
telefondaki ses koruyucu aileliğimizin
başvurunuzun kabul edildiğini,
ertesi gün bizi beklediklerini söylüyordu.
Çok heyecanlıydı elbette bizim için.
Çünkü ben bir çocuğun hayatına dokunmak
üzere, anne olmak üzere oraya gidiyordum.
O güne kadar 44 yaşındaydım.
Yoğun bir iş hayatım vardı .
Bir köy çocuğu olan ve çok büyük
zorluklarla inşaat mühendisi olmayı
başaran, şirket kuran ve giderek büyüyen
bir şirketin yöneticisi olan
babamla birlikte çalışıyordum.
Bu yoğun iş hayatının içerisinde,
biyolojik çocuk sahibi olmak da
hiçbir zaman önceliğim olmamıştı .
Ve ben elbette başarılı ve mutlu olmaktan
dolayı kendimi iyi hissediyordum.
Bireysel konfor alanından içerisinde
iyiydim, ancak her gün o yoğun çalışma
hayatından eve döndüğümde, yaşım bas -
başımı yastığa koyduğumda ben bu hayata
bunun için gelmiş olamam
diyordum kendi kendime.
Çünkü bende eksik olan bir şey vardı .
Tamamlanmamış bir şey ve ben hayatımın
anlamını arıyordum aslında.
Hani bir yapboz olur ya,
bu yapbozun birkaç parçası
eksik olduğu zaman tam
gözükmez o yapboz daki manzara.
İşte ben öyle hissediyordum kendimi.
Eksik bir şeyler vardı hayatımda.
Çünkü ben ben olmayı biliyordum
ancak biz olmayı bilmiyordum.
Atatürk Çocuk Yuvası’ndan içeriye
girdiğimde, önce bahçe beni büyüledi;
kocaman, yemyeşil bir bahçeydi.
Etrafta tarihi eserler vardı.
Şaşırdım. Allah Allah dedim.
Ne ki bunlar?
Sonra bana tarif edilen binanın önüne
geldim ve bir levha gözüme ilişti.
Umay Pavyonu yazıyordu.
İlk kez duyduğum bir kelimeydi Umay.
Ne demek acaba Umay Pavyonu dediğimi
ve anlamlandırmadığımı
çok iyi hatırlıyorum.
Sonradan öğrendim ki Umay, Türk
mitolojisinde çocukları koruyan ruh
demekmiş.
Fuat Bey,
Birinci Dünya Savaşı’nda özellikle
korunma ihtiyacı olan çocuklar için
çok önemli çalışmalar yapmış;
ve Himaye-i Etfali,
yani bizim bildiğimiz ismiyle
ve sonradan değiştirilen ismiyle
Çocuk Esirgeme Kurumu’nu kurmuştu.
O dönemde, çocuklar için önemli çalışmalar
yapmış, pullar çocukların resimlerine
bastırmış, bağışlar toplamış ve
hatta 23 Nisan fikrini Atatürk’e
kendisi vermişti.
Soyadı Kanunu çıktığı zaman da Atatürk,
Fuat Bey’e Umay soyadını uygun görmüştü.
İşte Umay Pavyonu, Fuat Bey’in
soyadını taşıyan binaydı.
Fuat Umay, bütün maddi
sahip olduğu her şeyi bağışlamıştı.
Ancak İsmet İnönü’nün önerisi ile
bu iki katlı, o dönemde yapılan, o dönemin
en büyük çocuk koruma yuvası olan
Atatürk Çocuk Yuvası’na o binaya
verilmesine izin vermişti.
Ben, asıl büyük şoku ve derin sarsıntıyı
o Umay Pavyon’dan içeriye girdiğim
zaman yaşadım.
0-3 yaş çocuklarının kaldığı
bir binaydı orası.
Üst katta bebeklerin yattığı karyolalar.
Aşağı katta da çocuklayın -
çocukların oyun alanları vardı.
İçeriye girdiğimde, onlarca çocuk
etrafta oyun oynuyorlardı.
Hepsi birbirinden güzeldi.
Şunu hissettiğimi hatırlıyorum.
Ne kadar güzeller.
Çünkü çok şaşırmıştım.
Bana anlatılanlar, öğrendiklerim,
ön yargılarım, toplumun bana öğrettiği
normlar bunlar değildi.
Bunları beklemiyordum.
Ve bakım verenler son derece
güler yüzlüydü.
Etraf çok düzenliydi.
Fakat asıl beni derinden sarsan şey,
çocukların gözleriydi.
Çocukların gözleri donuk bakıyordu.
Ben o gözlerdeki donuk ifadeyi
hiçbir zaman unutmadım.
Ve sonradan öğrendim ki aslında,
sevgisizlikmiş çocukların
gözlerindeki ifade.
Sevgi ile sarınılmadığı zaman
çocuklar iyi olmazmış.
Sevgisizlik aslında, çoğumuz bilmeyiz
ama en büyük şiddetmiş.
Güvenli bağlanamayan, sevgiyle büyümeyen
her çocuk aslında hayata son derece eksik
başlarmış .
Ben tabii bütün bunları çok
daha sonra öğrendim.
Müdür hanımın önüne oturdum.
Bana dedi ki ″Kız çocuğu ve bebek
istemişsiniz, Ülke Hanım.″
″Evet″ dedim.
Çünkü yeni öğrenmiş -
öğrenilmişliklerim ve bana anlatılanlar
ve bildiğim kız çocuğu olursa,
benim olursa ve küçük olursa,
bebek olursa
çok daha kolay olacak diyordu.
Oysa yine sonradan öğrendim ki,
hangi yaşta ve cinsiyette olursa olsun,
hangi travmaya sahip olursa olsun,
dokunulan her çocuk, ilgi gören her çocuk,
sevilen her çocuk iyileşir ve
travma döngüsü kırılırsa,
yoksulluk döngüsü kırılırsa
bir nesil değil, nesiller kurtulur.
İşte koruyucu ailelik bir nesli değil,
nesilleri kurtaran çocuk koruma
sisteminin en önemli basamaklarından
birisidir.
Ve bana dedi ki, ″Tanışmak ister misiniz?
İki aylık bir bebeğimiz var, adı Ela.″
″Evet″ dedim.
İster istemez miyim?
Nasıl istemem?
Kızıma getirdiler.
Pembe bir battaniyenin içerisindeydi.
Kucağıma aldım, uyuyordu.
Yüzü örtülüydü.
Açtım.
Çok güzel bir bebekti.
Çok güzel, çok güzel dediğimi ve
çok ağladığımı hatırlıyorum.
Müdüre Hanım çok deneyimliudi ve
dezavantajlı çocuklarla çok önemli
çalışmalar yapıyordu yıllardır.
Bana dedi ki, ″Ülke Hanım, bizim
çocuklarımızın hepsi çok güzeller.″
Bütün çocuklar çok güzeller.
Ben aslında, oradaki o derin manayı da
çok sonra anladım.
″Evet″ dedim.
″Gerçekten çok güzeller.″
Sonra kızım gözlerini açtı .
Simsiyah gözleri vardı,
yine çok donuk bakıyordu o da.
Çok kısa bir süre önce, oraya teslim
edilmiş olmasına ve koruma altına alınmış
olmasına rağmen,
simsiyah çok güzel kirpikleri vardı.
Gözlerini açtı derin derin gözlerimin ta
içine baktı ve eşime dedim ki,
″Bana bir şey anlatıyor.
Bu normal bir şey değil.″
Ben şimdi, kızımın bana
ne anlattığını çok iyi biliyorum.
Bana dedi ki, ″Anne,″ dedi, ″Çocuklar var,
ihtiyaçları var
sevilmeye.
Biz seninle yeni bir yola çıkıyoruz.
Benden bize giden bir yola çıkıyoruz.
Bir seyahate başlıyoruz.
Hazır mısın?″
dedi bana.
Biz kızımla Umay Pavyon’un önünde,
fotoğraf çektirdik ve çıktık.
Yaklaşık bir hafta sonra,
bambaşka bir çocuk vardı ve ben,
kızımı doğurmadı mı hatırlamıyordum.
Gözleri ışıl ışıldı .
Gülüyordu.
Ağlıyordu.
Sesler çıkarıyordu.
Bu değişikliğe hepimiz çok şaşırıyorduk
nasıl böyle bir şey olabilir diye.
Oysa bütün bunlar sevgiden, ilgidenmiş.
Ve ben kızımı doğurmadığıma
hatırlamıyordum.
İşte o zaman ben anladım ki, başkasının
çocuğu diye bir çocuk kavramı yok.
Her doğan çocuk hepimizin.
Ve her dokunulan çocuk iyileşiyor.
Ya peki diğer çocuklar ne olacak
diye yola çıktım.
Fuat Umay’ın çocuk davası,
artık benim de çocuk davamdı.
Korev - Koruyucu Aile Evlat Edinme
Derneği ile tanıştım.
O güne kadar çok önemli çalışmalar
yapmışlardı ve 2016′dan beri de
arkadaşlarımla birlikte,
öncelikle koruyucu aileliği anlatmak,
bir başka doğum hikayesini anlatmak.
Kan bağıyla değil, ama can bağıyla aile
olmayı, kalpten aile olmayı anlatmak üzere
yola çıktık ve bütün çocukların çok
sevildiği bir aile ortamında olmaları
için çalışıyoruz.
Ancak tabi asıl önemli olan burada,
Türkiye'de çocukla ilgili çok
önemli bir sorun var.
Çocuk, muhtaç kavramıyla eşleştiriliyor.
Oysa çocuk, büyümekte olan ve
bizim ona eşlik ettiğimiz, 18 yaşına kadar
uluslararası sözleşmelerle çocuk
olarak kabul edilen bir varlık,
bir birey hiç kimsenin aslında sahibi
olduğu bir varlık değil.
Dolayısıyla biz aslında, çocukla ilgili
zihniyeti değiştirmek üzere
çocuk kavramının başka bir noktaya
evrilmesi için çalışıyoruz.
Her çocuğun, iyilik halinin sağlandığı
ulusal, sürdürülebilir, kapsamlı,
bütüncül çocuk politikalarının
oluşturulması için çalışıyoruz.
Çünkü biliyoruz ki aslında ülkenin
geleceği çocuklukta kurulur.
Eğer özellikle
öğrenim çağından önce, ilk öğrenim
çağından önce çocuklar korumazsa,
maalesef ileriki süreçlerde de o
çocuklardan başarılar elde etmek ve
ülkeyi kurtarmak mümkün değildir.
Biliyor musunuz,
Atatürk de aslında bir koruyucu babaydı
ve evlat edinen bir babaydı.
Onlarca koruyucu ailesi olduğu çocuğu
ve evlat edindiği çocuğu vardı .
Hatta kızının ismini Ülkü
diye kendisi koymuştu.
Kızlarından birisi Sinem.
Geçen hafta, Atatürk -
Atatürk’ün önümüzdeki günlerde,
10 Kasım’ı anma töreni olacağı için
okulla birlikte Anıtkabir’e gitti ve
bana hediye olarak bunu almış .
Çünkü benim çocuklarım, Atatürk’ün çocuk
davasını bugünlere kadar taşıyan ve
bundan sonrası için de -
benim yol almamı,
sizlerin yol almasını anlatmam için
bana yol açan çocuklar.
Aslında dinlersek,
bütün çocuklar çok özeller,
hepsi bir iyiliği ve sevgiyi yaymak için
bu dünyaya geliyorlar.
Dünya, eğer biz başkasının çocuğunu
seversek ve o pamuklar içerisinde
koruduğumuz biyolojik çocuklarımızın
dışında başka çocukların da olduğunu
ve onlara dokunmamız
gerektiğini anlarsak, iyileşecek.
Benden bize doğru seyahat
edersek, iyileşecek.
Ben kızlarımla tamamlandım.
İşte o bütün olan - bütünlendim ve
o yapboz tamamlandı .
Bugün buraya kadar beni taşıdılar ve
benim kızımın sizinle bir resmini
paylaşmak istiyorum.
Ne zaman umutsuzluğa düşsem,
ne zaman birazcık yorulsam,
ne zaman yeter, dur desem ya da
engellerle karşılaşsam,
böyle bana mesajlar veriyorlar.
Her ikisi notlar bırakıyorlar, resimler
yapıyorlar ve diyorlar ki,
″Devam, yola devam.
Daha çok kişiyi anlatmalısın,
daha çok çocuk sevgiyle buluşmalı,
daha çok insan anne-baba olmalı.″
Kızımın resmini sizinle
paylaşmak istiyorum.
Diyor ki kızım,
″Duyduk duymadık demeyin.
Çocukların güvende olmasını istiyorsanız,
biraz saygılı, çocuklara iyi bakan
birisi olun.
Mutlu ve güzel bir ailede yaşıyorsanız,
çok şanslısınız demektir.
Mesela ben öyle.
Mutlu olun.
Zengin olmak sadece zengin olmak değildir.
Zenginlik iyi davranılmasıdır
evin içerisinde.
İllaki can bağı da - illaki
kan bağı değil, cam bağı da olabilir.
Koruyucu aile olabilirsiniz.
Beni dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkür ediyorum hepinize.
(Alkış)